how M I'm not going to listen to you
fool uh OKC OKC let's go with the
Brooklyn Net let's go instead with the
Dallas Mavericks I gave you the
Detroit the Utah
Jazz once upon a time but now he's with
the Orlando three chances brother yes we
do
Lonnie the
Brooklyn you have got a
[Music]
correct get him Craig play
for I'm going to go with the Sacramento
Kings oh so close it's the Chicago world
who we play for Hall of Famer this every
year every year l l baby Garrett Temple
is now on his 12th team wow he did he
break Chucky Brown who is it I'm going
go
with the Detroit Piston oh my goodness
it's not far away it's the Toronto R he
he had another country